happy birthday eva longoria celebrates  her husband jose antonio Basten's  birthday in the most luxurious way  possible we just fun et has the pics the  actress and her hubby living it up on a  yacht  the pair look to fit and fabulous  sailing off the coast of Hawaii so Oahu  eva in a palm print one-piece jose and  bright swim trunks tell me all about it  memorable romantic Eva and her man  exchanged I Do's in a lavish ceremony in  Mexico last May ET spoke with the  brunette beauty just days after  returning from her honeymoon the whole  night was magical giving me goosebumps  now that it was the centerpiece of the  wedding was love and that is really what  every wedding should feel like  [Music]